the ocean harvest is plentiful
enough to provide the islanders
and to support a thriving export
industry
but in the maldives land to grow fruit
and vegetables
is limited
crops like these
are both valuable
and valued
so this is dying
muhammad adam has struggled
his farm is close to the shoreline that
brings risk
all this is done yeah
storm surges are more frequent they
damage and sometimes kill his crops
including
his beloved banana trees
the extreme weather mohammed describes
is driven by climate change
and it's threatening to destroy the
maldives killing its coral reefs and
submerging the islands the maldivians on
their own
are powerless to stop this
but they are doing what they can to
protect their country
this is
better known as trash island
up to 700 tons of domestic waste was
dumped here every day
and burned
belching toxic fumes into the atmosphere
after 30 years the fire is finally out a
modern waste plant producing green
energy will be built here
what we are doing is what has to be done
as a responsible nation as a responsible
government as a responsible country with
citizens who are who are
who are dying to breathe in fresh air i
think
i i personally couldn't have imagined to
be standing in the middle of this
volcanic
landfill and still breathe in clean air
moldivians understand the climate
threats facing their nation for years
they've been asking the world for help
the challenge facing the maldives is
making people understand the extent of
the crisis that faces this island nation
when you see turquoise blue water and
golden sand you don't think
of an emergency but you have to remember
these islands are home to 400 000 people
there is already talk of relocating
vulnerable coastal communities
if that happens
more than lives and livelihoods will be
lost